hello everyone as some of you may have
noticed I really enjoyed chess and the
beautiful game like this played by a
nice gear is simply a must show this
game was played yesterday it's a round
five of the European team Chess
Championship and the Giri is playing
against Constantinople s cool top rated
Grandmaster from Romania he was a four
times a World Cup participant and he is
an a known expert in dynamic openings
unfortunately for him
Giri doesn't play the dynamic openings
as much so we have C 4 and Giri has the
white pieces and he goes for the English
opening c5 g3 g6 Bishop to g2 and Bishop
to g7 the symmetrical variation Knight
to c3 Knight to c6 the ultra symmetrical
variation Knight to f3 and d6
gira castles we have E 5 and now a3
going probably for rugby 1 and B 4 and
Lupescu plays a5 stopping any b4 ideas
but unfortunately this leaves the be 5
square available for gear is night in
the future we have d3 90 G to e7 and the
bishop to d2 Aguirre is in no rush to
push this epon to e3 or definitely e4 he
wants to have this pawn to e3 option
available and while it's something
Philidor thought us long ago after you
push a pawn forward it can never go back
solo place two castles we have rook to
be one Bishop to e6 and Giri goes for
Knight to g5 this e six square is a
beautiful square for the bishop but it's
not gonna stay there Giri doesn't allow
it so hopeless school admits that this
was kind of a mistaken place Bishop back
to c8 and we have Knights to b5 now by
giri as well
ADF I moved it allow it and now maybe
maybe even a move like Knights to a7 is
an idea to get rid of this pesky night
immediately but what pillai school goes
for a more active approach he plays f5
expanding on the on the Kings side we
have Knight to f3 by giri he doesn't
want to allow his night to get stranded
there on g5 h 6
and now before we have a capture some
before a capture some before and now v6
nice to e1 we have Bishop to e6 now now
the bishop can go to e6 ninth to c2 and
the Giri is getting ready to to activate
both of his knights on the Queen side
rook to b8 and now Knight to c3 we have
King to h8 be captures on c5 be captures
on c5 and rook captures on b8 Queen
captures on da and now Knight the a3
over protecting this be 5 square and
soon
this night will occupy it Queen to a7 we
have night the b5 by Gary Queen to d7
and queen to a4 rook comes to be 8 and
now Queen to c6 adding more pressure to
this c6 Knight and here is a very
interesting moment in the game as this
Knight is attacked twice it's defended
twice as well by the Queen and by this
night on e7 what look let's go here
plays Queen to d8 as he is known as an
expert in dynamic play it seems that
he's allowing this bishop to capture the
night which he kind of is but he
probably doesn't know it
give he does play Bishop captures on c6
and we have rook to be 6 and now would
an attack on the Queen after the Queen
moves Knight captures Bishop on c6 or
Roe captures Bishop on c6 it seems like
he's getting the piece back but he
replaced Queen to a8 and we have rook to
b8 again what a temple on the Queen the
Queen has to go back and if Geary would
play Queen to a6 Laplace would probably
continue with rocked the b6 and well
this would probably lead to a repetition
of moves but unfortunately for Lupescu
after this rook to b8 move giri plays
rook to a-1 he offers his queen 4 for
some extra dynamic play rook captures on
a 8 we have rook captures on a 8 now
would it would an attack on the Queen
Bishop to see a defending and we have
Bishop to g2 so the knight cannot
turret King to h7 and getting the King
back from the eighth-ranked Knights to
d5 now we are Knight to c6 and h4 we
have E for probably I mean if okay he
did play E for but it's really hard to
find a plan for black here maybe a move
like Queen d7 to get the Queen out of
the pin but other other than that I see
no real plan for black we have E 4 D
captures on e4 and now Queen to d7 we
have night to b6 sorry and Queen to b7
rook captures on c8 Queen captures on b6
and now he captures on f5
opening up a discovered attack from this
bishop to the knight on c6 Knight to d4
we have F captors and g6 with check King
to g6 and the bishop to e4 King to f7
and now Rock the c7 with check King to
g8 and rook to a7 and this is a
beautiful move by Gary this rook to a7
not allowing the Queen to get into the
game with Queen to a6 and also with with
plenty of trickery if for example a
loophole ESCO decided to play Knight
capture some b5 the game is over
immediately because rook to e8 check
King to f7 and now Bishop to a5 and the
Queen is trapped
so after this rook to a7 who plays who
tried the d5 we have Bishop captures on
d5 with check King to h7 Bishop back to
e4 check King to g8 and now Rob the a8
with check King to have 7 Bishop to d5
with check came to g6 and now rook to e8
paralyzing this knight on d4 because if
the knight moves
rook three six wins the Queen so Bishop
to f6 we have h 5 and this h5 is also a
beautiful move by Gary if you capture
the pawn for example King captures on h5
you get a bishop to f7 check and after
King to g4 rook to e4 check King to h3
elites the checkmate and well if you
play King to a5 this also leads to a
beautiful checkmate g4 sacrificing the
rook King captures now Bishop the leaf I
would check King to e5 and now f4 this
is checkmate
so after h5 loophole a school doesn't
accept the pawn he plays came to h7 now
you have Knights to d4 capturing the
knight see characters on d4 and Bishop
to f4 Bishop to g5 was played rook to e6
now with a temple on the Queen Queen to
be won check King to g2 Queen to d1 and
here we have better captures on g5 h
captures on g5 and h6 and in this
position Constantine Lupo ESCO resigned
the game as there is well nothing for
black to do here there is no point he
can even attack and let alone capture
there is simply nothing he can play and
the whites plan is completely
straightforward if you try something
like King to h8 you get a bishop to e
for protecting h7 preparing the pawn to
come to h7 and after for example Queen
a4 and Bishop to g6 you threaten
checkmate or winning the Queen and II
hate and well a couple of more moves
this is all over the King comes into the
game and the game is over
so after this h6 move Lopez could resign
the game and Geary achieved this
brilliant victory so good game onigiri
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
oh yeah forgot to mention after five
rounds of the European team chess
championship the first place Croatia has
the first place followed by Hungary in
second place in Russia in third place so
quite an interesting result for Croatia
definitely and madam Basia Church from
Croatia has has an amazing result three
and a half points out of four games
quite quite a result the best player of
the championship so far as
rather of Mamedov of azerbaijan with
four and a half points out of five games
so yeah that's some additional info I do
hope you enjoyed it thank you for
watching and I'll see you soon